foreign  [Music]  [Music]  please  um  [Music]  [Applause]  activities in these sort of created  spots outside because engaged with so  it's pretty cool it's pretty cool but do  they still like going outside I mean  today's obviously really Frosty but  honor of day today  [Music]  I've been in child care for about 10  minutes yeah I love it it's a passion  for me it's so important I love all the  children and what's important is over  the very best yeah that's right yeah and  how long have you been basically  and I've been helping out a lot yeah and  I'm scared  so I've been here helping out and as I  say for the past year and then I'll  check  yeah I'm not from now  with the ideas about it are there lots  of them working around things which  would ethosities  [Music]  as well as just new jobs  [Music]